I have a question would you say body
count doesn't matter I don't care at all
so what's your body count
[Music]
it doesn't everything
Matt it doesn't matter
um 15. 50 no one five no fifty fifteen
fifteen
fifteen okay fourteen fourteen mine's
one one really
okay okay you know you know it's crazy
you guys are the most honest we're like
everyone else have asked virgin I'm a
virgin
the only reason I ask is because if it
doesn't matter then everyone should just
say it and that's why I hesitated a bit
because I was like oh my God but then
it's like do you actually care like if
it doesn't matter like why do you know
what I mean it makes no difference to my
life it doesn't change me as a person
like it has nothing to do with my
personality or anything so so Devil's
Advocate do you think that sex is
different for men and for women and like
the way we experience sex so like we
have to have more of an emotional
connection with a guy I wouldn't say
much of an emotional connection I say is
different in the sense of like amount of
effort that are put in and I think a lot
of the industry and like the sexual
industry is based around a man's
pleasure not a woman's and like there
was a um a statistic and it was like
literally 65 of women I'm just saying
ballpark yeah I can't remember it but
they were like they watched lesbians
because it's based around like women's
pleasure so people get off easy to it
like most of the marketing is geared
towards women not met so I'm not for
corn you're correct like for the corn is
definitely geared towards men but 70 to
80 of consumer buying decisions
decisions are made by women like women
have more debt even though they make
less money because we spend more money
than men do by and large so like Society
actually isn't really geared towards men
it's geared towards women so like that's
why we have like like plus size models
for example like men typically like they
date smaller girls yeah they like just
by and large right not trying to you
know but like that's for the women it's
not for the Mad yeah well like I think
women want that as well like women want
to see you don't want to go and buy a
item of clothing that's shown on like a
size 4 model because you don't know how
it's going to look on your body type so
I think the brands that show like say
even just three different body types
it's like so much better because at
least people know what kind of ballpark
they're going to especially with buying
online and how big it's become no I
you're right but that like the only
point I was making is that it's geared
for women it's not geared for men so
like a lot of times we'll say like we're
in a patriarchy things like geared
towards men but it's not because women
are spending the money which we don't
even have because this agenda fake up in
the first place it's like oh you know
the pain that's a whole other combo I
know it's closing but you know no it's
it's like based on the industries we
pick so like women pick jobs that make
less money like by and large like for
example do you want to be a plumber how
many bodies is too many bodies for
someone you want to date like if they
said a thousand would you be cool a
thousand I'd just be shocked I'd be like
how the [ __ ] do you have the time to
always you must be seeking like one
person a day and different people all
the time like just how do you have the
time in your personal space I just think
as long as you're up to date with your
sexual health and as long as you care
about your body and care about the
people you are sleeping with and have
respect for them I don't care how many
people you've sat with as long as you
just have respect for my Sexual Health
on your own that is like a thousand
you'd be chilling a thousand I'd just be
like what the [ __ ] like how on Earth
could you possibly get to that point
that would be my only reservation but
I'd be like look have you been to the
clinic like do you you know look after
yourself if you look after yourself I
don't care who you've sat with how many
people whatever as long as you're you
know just respectful of us in like an
intimate space okay that's it yeah no I
agree I don't think like for me it's not
really a factor that I consider if I'm
in a relationship like as long as I'm
like the only person that's fine what
they did in the past like it's their
body it's their life they could do what
the [ __ ] they want yeah I think I don't
think it'd be like a deal breaker but
again I'd be shocked every
everyone everyone like as well it's also
nobody else's business how many people
you've sat with I think the person that
you're sleeping with that's new it's
their only business with you is to be
like well are you like are you within
sexual health or are you sexually ill in
that sense I don't think it's anyone's
business to even ask you like how many
people have you slept with because like
that's a new partner like you shouldn't
be talking about past sexual I mean you
can talk about pasture I always I always
ask I always ask but like it's like the
only thing I'd ask someone is like have
you got anything are you sexually safe
you know whatever and like I would never
be like oh how many people are stuck
with that's disgusting you know what I
mean I have a question when I'm asking
like I ask a guy about sometimes but the
reason I do is because I'm trying to
gauge if he's ready to settle down
because to me like I really want to get
married and have a family and like if a
dude slept with a thousand girls I'm
like I'm gonna be a thousand and one and
lock you down yeah and Percy like I was
single for a really long time and I'm
just really picky with the relationship
so like I should be yeah exactly and
like everyone was just kind of like and
there was a lot of boys that were like
oh she seeps around and I don't even
like sleep around that much based on
like say the general population not that
I care if I did but they were kind of
like oh well she like it's almost like
the connotation that you'll cheat on
them because you're sexually active yeah
and it's like faithfulness in a
relationship has no correlation to how
many people you've slept with like
within you know whatever divorce rate
does really yeah yeah it's like if a
girl's a virgin she's an 80 chance of a
happy marriage where if she slept with
more than five it drops to 25 but also
men too they don't talk about this but
like men like they had the longest the
best results are when both are virgins
is that not the sense of like kind of
the science of it when it's like did it
say it releases like um
um like oxytocin or something like that
and then you become like attached to
that person so if you're a virgin and
you marry someone and then they take a
virginity like you have that like mental
attachment literally through science
yeah so that's my only explanation for
it well I think it's the psychology of
choice yeah like if you'd slept with a
hundred guys like you're gonna there's
gonna be a lot of them that you liked
yeah and so it's like when you with the
new guy like you can't help but compare
in some way like people people act like
they don't but like I'm sorry you're
going I think it's also good to have a
comparison though because you kind of as
you're going along and as you're going
up and as you're with different people
like you get to know what you like and
what you deserve as well which is I
think is really important yeah and like
you know like the kind of personality
you want and like it's not even down to
like a lot of the time it's not for me
it's not a down to like attractiveness
or anything because like so many people
could be absolutely gorgeous and be
boring or not have the same music taste
as me or not like the same events as me
and like do you know what I mean I'd
rather go for someone that I'm
necessarily not like oh my God I love
you like you're so attractive but more
like oh my God you have a sick
personality you're really funny you're
like the same events to me the same
music as me like we're gonna have so
much fun and you know I'm curious how
old are you 21. okay okay I hear that
from Girls when they say that usually
they're like 27 28 yeah where they like
don't want the like the bad boys anymore
like the hot guys but I'm just so you're
you're early I'm over it like I'm bored
like I don't mind a bad boy if it's not
going to be a long-term thing because
then I'm like I don't have to deal with
it they don't make good boyfriends and
I'm like I don't care about a bad boy
like I'll sleep with them but if they're
like oh do you want to go on a date I'm
like no like I can read you straight
away and I know exactly what kind of
person you're like without being
judgmental about how they speak and how
they act I'm like this is not going to
be a relationship I'm curious would you
sleep with a bad boy quicker than you
would sleep with a nice guy it depends
like a guy that you want a date actually
it depends like personality wise I like
sleeping on the first date I don't care
because it takes this big discourse
about like women sleeping with someone
on the first day and it's like oh you're
not desirable anymore but it's like it
takes two to tango the man's also set
for somebody on the first date like does
it matter like oh as if I turn around
and be like oh you sent me on the first
day what the hell at the end of the day
sex is such a natural thing like if you
wanna if you're like on a date with
someone you're having such a good time
and you get to that stage why not
because the end of the day if you want
to be together you're going to end up
having sex along the line so why does it
matter the amount of time like that's I
mean that's one like trait of thought
I've heard a lot of people say is
because like it's like he's either gonna
stay or go after you sleep with him so
it's like I don't care yeah but then at
the same time it's like you also don't
know him that well so like I don't know
either yeah I think I've never slept
with a total stranger I've met people
even on dating apps but like we've had
mutual friends so like out of a point of
safety maybe if I completely didn't know
someone I wouldn't see with them but
only I have a point of safety not have a
point of being like Oh I set them on the
first day that's the only reason yeah
like I've owned literally only like kind
of say gone back after a first day with
people that like I know have mutual
friends with me and I know that they're
like fine I've asked my friends about me
every chance to steal you like they'll
know where you were yeah
random guy on a date I'd be like oh yeah
maybe we'll chat a bit more and then
I'll let you know my address but until
then [ __ ] no it's not happening